the White House is trying to dismiss
speculation about another staff shake-up
but high-level changes could be coming
soon sources tell CBS News the National
Security Adviser HR McMaster is likely
to lose his job and chief of staff John
Kelly could be resigning in the coming
days
Errol Barnett is at the White House with
more Errol good morning good morning
earlier this week President Trump
ominously told reporters he wants to see
new ideas and that he thinks the
American public wants to see things
shaken up yet another example that one
of the only constant aspects of this
White House is change we don't have any
personnel changes at this time press
secretary Sarah Sanders tried to shut
down rumors that National Security
Adviser HR McMaster could be on his way
out they just have actually spoke to a
number of staff this morning reassuring
them that there were no immediate
personnel changes at this time and that
people shouldn't be concerned but
sources tell CBS News McMaster is very
likely to be forced out the three-star
Army General replaced Michael Flynn whom
the president fired last February
still McMaster has clashed with the
president on key foreign policy issues a
reporter caught McMaster briefly outside
the White House Friday
everybody's giving White House
multiple sources also tell CBS News
chief of staff John Kelly could resign
soon Kelly was brought in last summer
from his post as head of Homeland
Security to instill order within the
West Wing joining him on thin ice
Housing and Urban Development Secretary
ben Carson and Veteran Affairs Secretary
David Shulkin Sanders defended the
president's right to make staffing
changes if the president wants to be
able to make a change because he feels
like it's the right thing for the
American people his hand shouldn't be
tied an unprecedented number of top
aides some two dozen have either
resigned been fired or reassigned in the
Trump administration now one potential
replacement for Kelly as chief of staff
is the current Office of Management and
Budget director Mick Mulvaney who was
also the acting director of the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau sources tell
CBS News Mulvaney is under serious
consideration for Kelly's job Anthony
Errol Barnett at the White House thanks
Errol